will you all three be coming back i am
not coming back unless luke
and katie and and ryan how am i gonna
juggle
doing vegas having a baby
yep katie's gonna have her hands full
juggling baby daisy
and her upcoming vegas residency with
today's official word
that all the judges and host ryan
seacrest will return to abc's american
idol next season
live virtual auditions kick off
nationwide friday
abc has also confirmed to et some
bachelorette news
that will make current hosts caitlyn
bristow and tasha adams
very happy will we be back for michelle
season we don't know but we sure hope
so we have had so much fun together they
will after the duo replaced chris
harrison on this season's bachelorette
the ink is dry for them to help michelle
young find love
when her season premieres october 19th
now
to abc's highest paid actor grey's
anatomy's ellen pompeo you gave me this
job to change things
so that's what i'm doing the reported 20
million dollars a year star made a
surprise career announcement on the
ladies first podcast
once she's done playing meredith gray
she may be done with acting
for good i'm not super excited about
continuing my acting career i have no
desire
to go sit in trailers at 11 o'clock at
night and wait to shoot scenes it's for
the young at heart
i miss you i know
this show's a tremendous money maker
let's be honest
um it makes a fortune for everybody
ellen will continue on graze for at
least another season
season 18 returns september 30. yes
we're starting to think about how you
would end a show this iconic
but we're not there yet we just take it
one season at a time